to meet with one of your groups in
tungle Click the contacts
icon and select
groups select the group you want to meet
with to see their schedules
overlaid click schedule a
meeting and when you arrive at the
invite step you'll see that all your
group members have already been
added if you want to let someone else
meet with your group
return to the contact
Section Mouse over the group
name and copy the
URL this URL is a custom page that shows
the overlaid availabilities of everyone
in your group and lets others request
meetings with you in your
group and finally you can create group
pages on the Fly
simply enter your tongle me
URL and add other URL extensions
separating them with a
comma for
example I can add two of my coworker
URLs to mine like
this and I have an instant group page
that I can send out to others or use to
schedule a meeting
myself if I need to include someone who
isn't a tongle me member I simply add
their email address to the
URL like
this their availability won't be shown
in the calendar view but they will
receive any meeting invitation sent
through this page and will be able to
reply without signing up